- Should we start with jeans?
T-shirts, tank tops?
There's too much shit in
here, I don't even know.
(upbeat electronic music)
- [Chris] Okay, so I'm here with Jazzmyne
and I remember telling people
that I was really intimidated
when I found out that
I was paired with her
because she dress so fly and so fresh.
Honestly feel like I'm all over the place.
Like some days I'll have
on a snap-back and like,
no makeup and a
windbreaker, and then today
I'm in eyeliner and lipstick.
So I really feel like
I'm all over the place.
- One of my friends told me
that I dressed like a lesbian,
and I was like, "That's
pretty dope, I'll take it."
- I don't know, she's very simple.
She doesn't go over the
top or anything like that.
- On days when I'm feeling lazy or tired
I might forego anything super stylish
and I'll just throw on a
t-shirt, a hat and a hoodie.
- I think I'm gonna wing it,
just because I kind of feel
like that's the spirit of
Jazzmyne's wardrobe anyways,
in which it's very free,
it's very unhinged.
- She keeps it really,
you know, casual, cute,
not really that many accessories.
So I'm gonna jazz that up a little bit.
- [Jen] We are here at Iguana.
- And I'm gonna make her look hot!
- Ooh, this is cute.
Look how small this is!
- The fact that I'm plus-size
will be interesting too,
because I feel like a lot of
people don't consider that.
Especially 'cause he's a smaller guy.
- All of these dresses are so tiny though,
I don't think these will work.
Well, oh, maybe this one.
No, that one's ugly.
- Do you think we should
get her a little jacket?
This is actually cute, do you
think she would wear this?
Should I get her this hat?
- As long as she wears the
right accessories with it,
I think she could do this.
The only questions is if it's her size.
- Nick has done my
makeup before and he went
for a pretty intense look,
which makes me wonder
whether he'll give me
something that is very vibrant,
or something that draws
a lot of attention to it.
- How cute are these with this jacket?
- Literally everything I see I'm like,
"God, she probably has this already!"
All of the fashionistas in the world
are probably gonna be like,
"What the hell are you doing?"
- Oh, wait a minute here.
Do you think that would be a little --
(laughs) No, I'm not
gonna do her like that.
- I'm pretty confident that I will be able
to pick something that she likes.
I think I'm able to knock
out the torso and pants
with one go, with this jumpsuit.
'Cause I know that she
can rock a jumpsuit.
- Yeah I could see her
rockin' something like that.
- At the very least I got
her a nice army jacket.
- [Nick] I think we got it.
She's ready to go out and
just have fun with the girls.
Just live her life and feel sexy.
- Okay are you ready to try these on?
- Mm, yeah.
- I'm not. Cool, let's go.
(drumkit beat plays)
- [Nick] Come on out!
- These shoes are too big.
- Oh my god!
- [Jen] I was gonna say.
- Woo! (laughs)
- Who would've thought I'd come
in here lookin' like trash,
and I'd come out lookin like this!
- Class!
- The glasses with your hair.
- Exactly.
- [Chris] Great. So good.
- How do you lesbians wear this shit?
- Usually the right size I guess.
- I like the jacket.
I love the gold chain, seriously.
This will up my game, definitely.
And this was adorable, it got over my ass.
- [Chris] I was freaking
out a lot over the jumpsuit,
but I'm at least thankful that
she was very understanding
and forgiving that it didn't quite fit.
- Shopping, one for women,
and two for a plus size woman
is not easy at all.
- At the very least
I'm glad that she likes
all the other stuff that I gave her.
- I thought I did an amazing
job, she looked so good.
- She's already fabulous,
but when you throw on
that fuck-me jacket and those
fuck-me pumps, she's so hot.
- I think Nick picked
out a really nice outfit.
I feel like I've just really
recently started figuring out
what my style is, and what
type of clothes I like to wear,
and I think Nick just added
a nice little bit of pizzazz.
(electronic music)